we have mr will clemente joining us will
what's going on
yo yo long time no see how you doing
fellas we're doing fantastic let's just
cut to the most important part of this
you got a surprise for us
oh yeah give me one second let me grab
it hold on ladies and gentlemen mr will
clemente has been busy he's been doing
things
trying to get ready for this exact
moment so john let's get a little
[Applause]
yeah
look at the puppy
what's the name of the puppy will hello
what what's the puppy's name he's cody
why uh what was the logic behind the
name or did you not have a say
girlfriend loved it man
and that's like that's the best reason
you got there well
all right let's do uh a little puppy
cody it looks like a friend for ranger
wait hold on what is that
doodle will uh you don't know this but
we we found a piece of lost technical
analysis that you did one time
[Laughter]
all right how are you feeling in terms
of uh sentiment on uh on twitter right
now
well uh me turning into a dog influence
there's got to be somewhat of a bottom
signal right
[Laughter]
it's no i mean i feel like people are
glad people are bearish yeah everyone
everyone's bored you got people like
starting to post like their workout
regimens people deleting their twitter
and
um i don't know i think that's also
reflected in a lot of
like you know network activity stuff on
chain or volume when you're just looking
at like inter exchange stuff i mean i
just think generally we're kind of just
you know consolidating and in the
meantime people are kind of finding
other hobbies or going to the beach
yeah i actually don't think that that's
necessarily bad for uh for the market to
have some consolidation here one of the
charts that you've got is literally the
consolidation that we're watching where
bitcoin's kind of trading in this range
um
is it just we need a catalyst to kind of
break out of the range or what's your
expectation uh do we just continue until
we get to uh some narrowing of it
no i mean it could be a catalyst that
breaks us out of it but um you know
generally speaking whenever you have
like a failed move out of one end of the
range and reclaim that tends to you know
if you have a failed breakout to the
upside it comes back within the range it
tends to be pretty bearish that's what
kind of what happened at the end of 2021
so seeing kind of this failed breakdown
um whenever it was like four or five
days ago to the bottom side of the range
and reclaimed uh that's you know
somewhat of a good sign but we'll see
where we break out should have you know
another week or two before we get you
know substantial move out of this kind
of consolidation here it's been about
two months now as of this week so yeah i
saw you tweeting about this idea of like
the price distribution i know you got
the chart um in terms of uh there's
almost like these levels as to uh uh the
distribution of where bitcoin last
trades how do you think about these
levels and their importance of uh both
you know kind of uh serving as some sort
of floor for the price but also some
sort of ceiling
yeah so like obviously as we just looked
at it's just price right um what this is
looking at is the actual on-chain volume
um so it's telling you the amount of
supply that's last moved at different
price levels so like opposed to volume
that's just telling you you know this
amount moved here this amount moved here
this is dynamic so you know if
let's say five percent of supply last
moved at 5k and then it's now moved at
20k
then
you know then that volume is gonna move
into that net other price level in this
chart um so that's where the realized
price aspect comes from because it's
based on when coins last moved
what you can see is basically like
the another way to visualize the
consolidation that we've been in is this
this kind of quote-unquote cluster of
volume that we've seen between
36 to 45 um and you can see like that
the gray bar is the gray just means
that's where we are right now you can
see we're in that really tight you know
mid part of this kind of consolidation
here yeah it's super fascinating that we
can get this data right i think that's
the part to me that just like yes the
the actual individual data sets are
really important but the fact that we
can see this at all times uh and
continue to analyze it just still blows
me away even after doing this for a
while um talk to us about uh the spot
premium and what you're seeing from an
actual price standpoint and then how you
also think that that uh kind of overlays
with uh uh you use quarterlies but but
the uh the difference in price if you
will uh with the futures and spot price
right so the the first chart you'll see
on the bottom something called
perpetual's basis so this is looking at
like the weighted average of all the
spot exchanges measured against the
weighted average of all the perpetual
swaps um and so the oscillator is
telling you in aggregate you know are
are perps trading at a premium or
discount to spot
and so whenever you're in green that
means that spot spot is currently in a
premium or perps or trading at a
discount to spot you know selling the
same thing
and then when we're in gray that means
that perps are trading at a premium to
spot
and so generally this is kind of a way
to highlight kind of you know exuberance
in the market especially from the
derivatives market as you can see on the
left hand side of the screen that's kind
of that october period of 2020 leading
up to that big run-up at the end of 2020
into early 2021. you can see that second
regime and the kind of midway through
last year over the summer
the kind of mini one we went through at
the end of september last year and
recently the kind of prolonged regime
that we've been in for over three months
now um of spot kind of leading perps
here
yeah it's fascinating to watch this um
and so if we look at the uh uh the next
one that with the quarterlys uh the
difference here exp take a second just
to explain what quarterlys are and and
why this is an important uh kind of
understanding of the difference between
spot and and uh the futures
sure so i think like the the way that
most people have heard of this is like
the cash and carry trade yep so
essentially what you're doing is you're
selling the future that's you know
whatever in this case we're talking
about three months out so you're selling
the three month feature buying spot and
then holding that out until expiry
capturing the difference
and so that you know that works when
when you go out on the futures curve
it's in contango meaning you know out on
the term structure each contract further
out is trading at a higher price
and so in early 2021 this got to insane
levels up to like 45
kind of at the you know peak of the
market top which meant that you know you
could do you know execute this trade and
get annualized 45 which is like
absolutely insane like i don't know if
we'll ever reach that level of
exuberance again
um
partially because you know the market is
just getting more efficient there's more
capital that's coming in that's going to
kind of do these arbitrages
and basically you know arbitrages are in
essence just trying to capture
inefficiencies in the market right and
so i doubt we'll ever get back up to
that 45 percent level and unless
something like absolutely insane happens
like the u.s central bank announces
they're they're allocating to bitcoin or
something like you know just like
completely outlandish like that um as
you can see as well like even at the end
of 2021 we still didn't even
nearly get to that you know that level
of uh the basis so
you know this is you know a driver of
capital into spot because as you know
the basis pushes up it's incentivizing
people to buy spot and then sell the
future um so i think that you know this
was
mo it was mostly the grayscale arb but
this played a role in it as well
and some of that capital inflow that we
saw in the spot at the end of 2020 into
early 2021 um and then it's a bit at the
end of last year uh but the the kind of
key thing that i want to highlight and
the reason i have the chart up is where
we are now so if you see in the bottom
right this is just kind of bleeding down
um and so like pretty much throughout
you know the chart history that's shown
on the screen you'll see that generally
this follows price
but you know kind of strangely over the
last call it you know two months or so
this has just kind of bled down while
price has kind of just been
consolidating um not quite bleeding
straight down like like the basis has so
to me this is kind of just indicating
there's like a lack of exuberance if you
will um you know from the derivatives
market and that you know
um
yeah exactly that like you know
essentially you're just you're seeing
less people interested in you know
taking this trade uh capital that's
perhaps kind of like waiting out to see
some decisiveness from the market and
just a nice reset in general from from
the derivatives market
got it and then if we go ahead and we
compare it to the actual bitcoin price
itself uh it looks even more obvious it
seems like right
yeah i think this is just another cool
way i mean i threw this together like 10
15 minutes ago i was just like towing
around in glass note actually um but
yeah like when you compare the basis to
price you could see something similar
basically telling you whenever this is
rising that you know you're seeing the
basis decline in relativity to the to
the bitcoin price
all right now let's take a look at the
actual on-chain metrics uh supply shock
ratios you and i have been talking about
this now for
almost two years going on
um it feels like uh it looks like we're
just seeing a repeat to some degree of
what we saw in the summer of last year
right
of the the supply shock really becoming
more attractive but but what's your read
on it
right so you know um i think like one of
the biggest misconceptions when people
see this is that
it's like digging in the hardwood floor
just trying to dig a hole to china
um you know i think the biggest
misconception is like first supply shock
by definition you need low available
float plus demand and so you know this
this metric is really telling you kind
of one side of the equation which is the
low available float so the higher that
this metric goes the lower the available
float is or the you know the
higher the qualitative aspect is of
bitcoin's flow because by definition
when the blue line is ticking up it's
telling you that there's more supply
moving to entities who have a lower
tendency to sell so
you know people who will often talk
about like the exchange balances and say
that oh that doesn't really have any
merit which by the way is the purple
line as the purple line increases
there's more coins being taken off
exchanges
you know the kind of argument there is
that oh
well people can just move coins right
back onto exchanges right and i mean
it's a valid argument um you know i i
don't fully agree with that but i could
i can understand the you know the logic
that you're that you're you know trying
to create there um but you know with a
liquid supply by definition it's telling
you the historical statistical
likelihood of those coins being spent
again so it's telling you coins are
moving to on-chain entities that have a
lower than 25
tendency to sell their coins so for
every four coins they take in they sell
um less than 25 percent of those coins
uh so seeing this uptick over the last
two weeks
you know in both of these is telling you
a coins are moving off exchanges but
they're moving to entities to have a low
history
of selling a lot of those uh you know
withdrawals have come from coinbase in
particular upon doing some kind of
further digging um but yeah i mean this
is a really large divergence i think
this is the largest divergence going
back in the charts history um you know
from like 2013 2014
um and you know when you look at this in
comparison like 2018
the big difference was you know it looks
very similar you know 2018 looks very
similar to like may on the left hand
side like may 2021 on this chart um you
know you saw this continually declining
declining declining until the to the end
of 2018 and it started to reverse again
so that there's a very big distinction
between late 2018 and what we're seeing
now is that you know this has continued
to you know grind up or you know in the
last two weeks push pretty aggressively
up but generally just grinding up
whereas you know in the 2018 bear market
you saw this decline more and more
so to me this is just showing you you
know overall that more supply is getting
locked up and it's basically you know
the analogy i like to use which i
actually stole from lynn alden who does
who's been kind of dabbling in on chain
analysis and i think she's you know she
gets it obviously she's really smart
she's been saying you know
the fuel is laid out you just kind of
need a spark for that fuel right and so
like the further that this you know
ticks up that's showing you there's more
and more fuel that's laying out so you
know it doesn't tell you that uh it just
tells you that there's a higher
likelihood or probability of there being
some type of supply shock where that
demand does kick in substantially i
think you know part of the reason that
every single time this ticked up in 2020
and kind of like early to mid 2021 and
like this was this and exchange balances
were just like you know i think that was
when like ever you know there was no
on-chain backlash or anything um i think
part of that was because like you had a
steady uh stream of demand coming in
because of the monetary backdrop right
so you just had like completely easy
money um you know qe infinity and so
that was generating just this constant
bid so every single time that the you
know
the float drew down you had that other
side of the equation which was the
demand and so now i think we're kind of
in the inverse where this you know the
the float is looking stronger but that
demand because of a lot of kind of the
uncertainty that we're working through
this month uh we had the fed hike rates
this week 25 basis points which is
really nothing compared to inflation but
nonetheless we're kind of working
through some of that um uncertainty
markets kind of digesting what's going
on in ukraine and russia
um and so yeah i think you know the big
thing though from from this chart is
just telling you about that the
qualitative aspect of that the float
which is one half of the equation
got it and then when we take a look at
this brand new metric uh i think it was
david puel and maybe checkmate uh if i
remember correctly um they created this
uh long-term holder inflation deflation
ratio uh you're gonna have to explain to
everyone what that means uh but it it's
just incredible to watch like we're
literally watching these metrics get
created in real time as a number of
smart folks continue to analyze the data
but what exactly is this metric showing
for sure so this is again as you said
created by david puel who's from
arkandest one of my good friends and
checkmate from glassnode he's the lead
analyst at glasnode
so their idea was uh you know relatively
straightforward it's just you know we've
been talking about long-term holder
supply for a long time but what they
kind of decided to do is kind of
obviously genius at the same time is
compare the rate of increase in
long-term holder supply
to bitcoin's issuance so it's basically
telling you the pace of you know the of
how fast long-term holder supply is
increasing which means two things it
means a short-term holders are aging
into long-term holders so they're aging
past that threshold to be considered
long-term holders as well as long-term
holders themselves accumulating um but
the two of those things combined uh lead
to long-term holder supply increasing so
they're looking at the rate of increase
the you know the the annualized rate and
increase of long-term holder supply
compared to bitcoin's issuance uh and
that's what that red line is here and so
as you can see this has been a actually
really strong signal
and we're at the highest that the ratio
has ever been which means that you know
essentially the kind of deflationary
aspect of long-term holders locking up
supply is at an all-time high um you
know throughout all of bitcoin's history
thus far
yeah this is wild that uh i i love the
kind of thought process of like we're
laying the fuel and just every metric
that you're showing right is we're
getting more and more data points that
kind of confirm this idea that yes there
is gonna have to be some sort of
catalyst uh but it's definitely uh
laying out there uh you've got market
inflation rate and derivatives uh here
as well um and when you look at this uh
it seems to be saying you know pretty
similar thing as well and we got kind of
this flash green uh on this
chart yeah so i basically took the exact
same methodology that i just described
with checkmate and david what they did
and then i just replaced a long-term
holder supply instead i added in or
replaced it with a supply that hasn't
moved then at least a year ago around
glasgow it's called supply last active
one year plus um so it's telling you the
amount of supply that hasn't you know
moved at all in one year or more um and
then it's telling it's comparing that
you know rate of change to bitcoin's
issuance again the same methodology we
just talked about just different metric
you know supply last active one year ago
instead of long-term motorspot uh and
what you see is whenever this reaches
this certain threshold that kind of i
highlighted here on the screen with the
blue line uh that has kind of a four for
four hit rate in terms of translating to
kind of positive price action for
bitcoin over you know a multi-month
basis obviously a lot of these things
aren't telling you what's going to
happen with price in the next few days
these are things that are kind of used
for you know
you know more broader term investors and
capital allocators that are
just looking for
better broad entry points into you know
allocating to btc with longer time
horizons
um and so like you know again this is
showing something very similar not quite
you know at the all-time high that the
uh previous you know the metric using
long-term motor supply is but again it's
showing you that we're getting to the
substantial level of supply getting
locked up it's just a different measure
of showing that same kind of dynamic
that we looked at in the last two charts
really
and then when we look at on-chain cost
basis uh obviously the price is trading
below that uh kind of on-chain cost
basis
what are the ramifications of that and
is it basically uh we shouldn't expect
to see
any more kind of um euphoria return to
the market to our backup over this
yeah i think that's that's a fair way to
put it you know like this is the metric
that
we kind of flipped cautious below once
we broke below it at 53k
um you know that was kind of where i was
like
yeah i don't i don't know like you know
we kind of lost a lot of the momentum a
lot of strength you know at the end of
december and i still think for you know
momentum i think there's value in
momentum buyers um and i you know until
we kind of reclaim this reclaim this uh
i don't think we've kind of
you know reclaimed that you know
momentum in the market
and so for kind of momentum-based market
participants this is one of the main
metrics that i would kind of want to
keep in mind in addition to just
traditional moving averages
the psychology behind this is basically
very similar to sober
so essentially it's telling you
where the average cost basis by
definition uh is of all the market
participants that have been in the
market for less than 155 days
and so at kind of a raging bull market
whenever you retest that cost basis
because you know bitcoin's just ripping
over several months time period people
are not going to want to sell there
they're not going to want to sell at a
loss in a bull market and so people say
okay hold on i'm not going to pay excel
i'm just going to you know wait it out
for a second and that allows the market
to some of the selling to subside market
moves back off that band um conversely
once you break below that people are now
under water and aggregate you know
shorter term market participants newer
markets newer market participants i
should say are underwater
and so every time you have an underside
re-test of that once those market
participants are underwater
the kind of thinking now changes to
oh this thing isn't going up anymore i
want to get out i just want to get my
money out i don't know why i bought this
i just bought it because it was going up
as soon as i get a chance to break even
i'm just going to gtfo right and so like
every time as you can see for example in
you know the end of 2018 we had four or
five kind of failed underside retests of
this band which is you know from a
behavioral aspect showing you that every
time the cost basis of these newer
market participants is retested they
decide that okay you know on that
break-even or very close to it i'm just
going to jump ship and and you know
break even and get out of this
ponzi scheme you know i'm just making
something up but you know the the
sentiment there is that i just you know
i just want to get out right because
this thing just doesn't stop going down
um and so like that's kind of why you
see it serve as resistance once it's
broken below and really strong support
once it's broken above um and so like
currently as you mentioned we broke
below that um around 53k
uh in the newsletter and i believe on
this show as well and on my twitter kind
of turned cautious once we broke below
53k had that failed underside retest
there at the end of december and since
then i've kind of failed to reclaim that
um that currently sits around 46k so
that's you know again an area that i'm
watching to see you know are we starting
to kind of reclaim some of that momentum
yeah it's um man it just feels like uh
uh it's pretty attractive and uh kind of
a repeat of summer 2021 joe john what
questions you guys got hey well what's
going on man uh so
fred in the comments he uh we're trying
to crowd some questions over here and he
just wants to know in your mind what is
the catalyst going forward like what can
jumpstart uh bitcoin's price again and
what are you looking for
yeah sure that's a good question uh you
know i think the biggest catalyst is
always the one you're at least expecting
right when whenever you know whenever
there's a
priorly known catalyst to the upper
downside that tends to get priced in
beforehand right
um and you know when whenever something
happens that no one knows is coming then
that market that information has to get
priced in in the moment like it has to
get priced in real time so like a good
example of this would be
like tesla announcing they bought
bitcoin uh i think on chain we saw some
interesting like stable coin inflows in
the days before so i think there might
have been like some insider front
running but generally the market in
aggregate you know didn't really see
that coming i think and so that's why we
had like a 20 god candle on the day that
tesla announced because the market was
pricing in that information in real time
um you know versus when you have kind of
you know a sailor announcing he's he's
gonna buy or you know uh just any kind
of event that that you know is is known
to the market beforehand it's gonna have
less of an impact once it finally
happens because the market's gonna you
know price that in leading up to that um
so that would be kind of the biggest
catalyst i would say is the one that we
have no ideas coming some of the obvious
ones though uh for example the el
salvador bond race right that's you know
supposed to be about 500 million dollars
of bad pressure coming into the into the
market
and when bitcoin is relatively illiquid
like this that can actually have a more
substantial you know market impact
uh another one obvious one would be like
a spot etf upside surprise uh i don't
have any and so you got to get the uh
the bloomberg guys on to to maybe talk
about the likelihood of that i know you
had like the valkyrie guy on last week
or something he was i listened to that
it was pretty good but um i don't have
any insight into that but obviously that
would be a big upside surprise
um and maybe just you know another kind
of uh central american country adapting
bitcoin or something of that sort um i
mean again it could just be
you know the kind of overall thing is
just we're kind of in this like murky
storm of macro uncertainty right and so
like maybe it just has to be
the whole russia ukraine conflict
sorting itself out um and you know the
fed kind of finishing their hike cycle
and obviously if they walked back
you know tightening expectations that
would be huge
i mean there's a few different things
but again overall not to repeat myself
several times but i think the biggest
thing would just be
um you know what what you're least
expecting you know and and you know if
something comes out that no one foresaw
coming that information is going to have
to you know get priced in in real time
gotcha will when you're thinking about
uh realized price and kind of new people
coming into the market and what we saw
in 2018 where people begin to sell once
they get to that like break-even point
thinking that
bitcoin has only been above this level
where it's at right now for like six
percent of the days what do you expect
to see the same thing if we get back to
those levels of 50 60 000 that people
are gonna newer market participants go
ahead and dump some coins and kind of
break even
you're saying if we if we reclaim that
yeah if we re if we start um in a bull
market and start going with price
appreciation here and it reaches 50 60
000
do you expect new market participants to
once they break even to jump ship
i mean i think you'll always have some
profit taking like in aggregate though
their cost basis the newer market
participants cost basis is at 46k
um and so like that's that's where that
level of break and even like in
aggregate is obviously like some is some
is above someone's below that's kind of
the aggregated number um but of course i
mean if we get up to 50 60k some people
will will take profit um but you know
it's it's all about you know is the
marginal buyer outweighing the marginal
seller and so kind of you know this this
metric paired with some other measures
of momentum um you know is a good way to
look at you know once that momentum is
reclaimed you have market participants
that are stepping in basically like you
know trend following market participants
so
you have like value market participants
that are looking at i don't know whether
it's an on-chain metric or the number of
days below moving average or just
general price structure you know there's
different ways to kind of determine
what's value for btc maybe just like
looking at order book interest
um so i think you have like those value
mark participants and then you have
momentum-based market participants
and so my i guess what i'm just trying
to say here is that if we were to
reclaim this um i think that you'll
start to see a lot of those kind of
momentum based market participants step
in not solely because of this metric i
think from
some of those behavioral dynamics that
we talked about you'll probably see
um a decrease in in aggregated spending
because those market participants are
now back in profit um but you know
there's also some other kind of
confluence around 46 47k price structure
uh the yearly open a couple different
moving averages some of those kinds of
things so uh i would kind of tend to
tend to you know
my my thesis here would be that if we
started to reclaim 4647k
uh doug kind of
have some of those trend based trend
following based uh you know momentum
market participants kind of step back in
and uh continue to push this higher got
to makes a lot of sense
well when you start to think about uh
looking forward
is there still a belief that like the
wall street folks uh who may be treating
this like a risk asset versus the retail
folks who treat it more like a reserve
asset does that framework still apply
here and then also how do you think
about some of the more macro stuff with
you know interest rates russia ukraine
having an impact on on those treating
this as a risk asset
sure yeah i mean i think first of all
like on the on the second question
listen to guys like luke groman or like
nick carter um i'm not gonna have
anything more valuable than those guys
so instead of like saying anything um
and maybe missing some of the important
points i'll say like turn to those guys
i'll tell you go listen to them um
because those are kind of the people
that i've been listening to in that
regard when all been as well obviously
she's always brilliant so listen to some
of those folks as to like kind of some
of those you know broader macro
uh
you know
effects of of kind of what's going on uh
to the first question yeah i think
generally like a lot of a lot of uh you
know wall street
you know esque folks are viewing bitcoin
as kind of a a risk on asset still
but at the same time i think recently
with everything going on with russia
ukraine i think you know bitcoins kind
of
some of the value proposition has
started to shine through especially once
you saw like russia's reserves get
essentially frozen right and so um i
forget the guy's name i don't want to
botch i think it's like zoltan from
credit suisse yes he had kind of wrote
in in his piece at the end you saying
you know this and you know in a few
years or so he's kind of saying in it in
a longer term sense this is probably
good for bitcoin everything that's going
on a kind of the uh you know the
dedolorization if you will um and then b
just kind of the realization that you
know
you shouldn't be trusting any nation or
any individual entity uh to like you
know custody anything um even gold right
like you know most of gold is kind of
consolidated in one area like even
countries that like have gold as a
reserve asset because it's so expensive
to move around like a lot of it is just
in one location
um and so i think like some of these
like you know events recently
especially with russia and some of the
canada stuff to like a lesser extent but
i think especially the stuff in russia
it's going to open people's eyes to
saying you know oh well you know
i understand like what the value prop is
here now it's censorship resistant money
you can take anywhere in your brain um
you know for if you're a refugee right
you don't have to like smuggle gold bars
in your backpack you could just memorize
12 words and take your wealth with you
anywhere on the planet um and you know
no one can take it from you or seize it
and so i think you know some of these
these recent events have definitely
started to highlight that to an extent i
think the biggest thing though is like
when when we're talking about russia you
know taking a bitcoin position or
something like that you know i think it
would be illogical but
what a lot of bitcoiners i guess maybe
kind of oversee and
it's just the fact that bitcoin really
isn't liquid enough right now
excuse me um you know like
we're just not big enough where
you know some kind of like massive
sovereign wealth fund or you know
central bank could step in and and take
a bitcoin position bitcoin's just again
not big enough for like amazon or an
apple like if they step in and take any
even like a percent or two percent
position
they're gonna like drive this thing up
right so it's gonna take time um just
for us to kind of generate the liquidity
uh for these market participants to kind
of get in and out um but i definitely do
think though
there's been a lot of people that have
probably looked at some of these current
events and started to realize albeit you
know again canada to a lesser extent but
really this this russia ukraine stuff um
you know whether you agree with russia
or not you know the facts are that you
know the united states can really lock
anyone out of the financial system in a
day or two right and and that's kind of
like a rude awakening for other nations
around the world
um and so yeah again i think there's
there's definitely uh some eyeballs and
what's going on here and uh people kind
of realizing having that kind of light
bulb moment if you will as to why you
know we we talk so much about why
censorship persistent money is so
important
when you think about um the market right
now is there any metrics that you
weren't looking at
three months ago that now you're paying
a lot more attention to i know that
you've got kind of a pretty um
uh
thorough process uh just given you know
the the day job but also just your
personal interest but like what is the
metric or two when you wake up you look
at first uh outside of price or
something that would be more elementary
yeah i mean i think it really comes down
to like
i say three or four things um depending
on like how we want to group them like
first of all when i wake up though i'll
just look at price right i mean really
you can look at just scroll through your
twitter you know twitter feed and gauge
sentiment to see if price went up or
down kind of like joking when i say that
but really i you know i'm just check
price see where price is at real quick
if there's a you know really large
moving price
you know i'll kind of work backwards and
say okay well you know bitcoin
absolutely dumped you know was there
some type of bad news that came out um
was it just you know some massive
leverage worked out that maybe i had
been watching out for over the last
couple days and kind of you know
look to see if there's anything
interesting going on there then kind of
just move to you know i have a couple
newsletters some subscribe to um just go
through kind of like general market news
just do a quick scroll through on cnbc
see if there's anything substantial and
market watch a couple of these different
things and then twitter like twitter is
honestly my main you know
uh source of information if you will i
have like you know several i'm a very
like not to sound snabby i'm just like
very selective with who i follow because
i like to like go through twitter and
basically have it as kind of like a
bloomberg terminal of sorts where i have
different people i follow for different
specific things
and then you know i can go through and
see all the different bits of
information that i find valuable from
different people that i find insightful
and then so like i'll say price
and then you know macro slash news the
other thing is obviously derivatives so
i'll use like a coinalize i use glass
note a little bit
and then i'll go through and kind of
look at you know what's going on with
open interest uh what's going on with
funding um you know spot premiums
discounts
did anything crazy happen with
quarterly's overnight i'll go and look
at order books see if any you know crazy
bids or asks stepped in and uh what's
going on across the different exchanges
there
and then lastly i'll go through and look
at you know what's going on from an
unchained perspective but you know
obviously
not a whole lot from a non-chain
perspective because by definition like
we're looking at kind of these broader
trends not a whole lot really changes
day to day you only really need to check
on chain like once a day uh because the
data updates at 8 30 uh est for me
because i'm on the east coast um but it
updates at the same time every day so
you know i'll just sit there on my
computer as soon as it uploads we're
like all right go through check
everything see if anything really
changed for the day
um generally the main stuff that's going
to change if it will is just like you
know
exchange balances obviously like the
liquid supply uh you know the
the
size of different cohorts supply
some of those kinds of things but
generally like you know when we're
talking about like these like broader
oscillators or you know some of these
kind of metrics that are trying to give
you you know an edge over like a several
months basis not a whole lot it's really
gonna you know kind of change day to day
but the derivatives obviously and then
and then the news uh those those are
kind of the two
the two things uh you get their order
books in there too but you know those
are the two things that are really kind
of like changing constantly throughout
the day i would say the other thing too
is like get in a couple really good you
know group chats
because you know i'm like 50 iq so i got
to be in all these group chats with all
these giga brains to help me kind of get
up to speed right um and so i'm in like
several different
uh
you know group chats with traders or
fund managers etc uh that you know i
kind of just sit back i try to you know
add some value not just lurk in there
but you know really i'm kind of in there
paying attention asking questions to to
other people smarter than me so i would
say like try to form a group of people
that
you think are you know are smart and
ideally smarter than you
um and you know are you know as excited
about the market as yourself and then
just kind of you know build off each
other i'm like i'm very big on the uh
the whole like stephen covey the the you
know uh
i'm gonna completely botch this but like
the
the the output is bigger than the sum of
the parts right like if you add you know
one plus one plus one it equals five
right because you're combining each you
know individuals uh you know skill set
together and when you have that kind of
synergy between those different parts
especially if you have like you know
several people in a you know telegram or
discord chat that all specialize in
something different or you bring that
together and like the kind of aggregated
output of the you know insight you're
gonna have into the market is much
stronger than any of you are gonna be
able to have you know individually so
those are some of the things i would say
but you know again the uh
the the group chats and just talking to
smart people has really been the the
biggest thing for me
um podcasts obviously and i keep adding
new stuff podcasts are in there too but
yeah again like talking to
talking to smart people is like really
the biggest thing man and like just
asking questions you'd be surprised how
many people are like
open-minded i know it's easy for me to
say that because i you know i have a
decent sized following but like you know
really even when i had like you know two
or three thousand followers i would
reach out to all kinds of people and
just be like hey what do you think of
this maybe you get ghosted like eight
out of ten times but you know two out of
ten times is better than zero so
you know just keep asking questions and
just uh stay hungry i think that that is
the key to all of this is the learning
is never done hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time